formasen parte o incluso fuesen el núcleo de nuestro equipo médico?
¿Y si Musu nos ayudase a llevar la asistencia médica de las clínicas
a las puertas de sus vecinos?
Musu tenía 48 años cuando la conocí.
Y pese a su increíble talento y ambición
no había tenido un trabajo remunerado en los últimos 30 años.
¿Y si la tecnología pudiese apoyarla?
¿Y si pudiésemos invertir en ella con una formación real,
dotarla de medicamentos reales,
y que tenga un trabajo de verdad?
En 2007 estaba intentando responder a estas preguntas,
y ese año mi mujer y yo nos casamos.
Pedimos a nuestros familiares que se olvidasen de los regalos de boda
y en su lugar donasen algo de dinero
para poder lanzar una organización sin ánimo de lucro.
Se los prometo, soy mucho más romántico que eso.
(Risas)
Finalmente reunimos USD 6000,
entre liberianos y estadounidenses
y lanzamos una organización, llamada "Last Mile Health".
El objetivo es tener un trabajador de la salud
al alcance de todos, en cualquier lugar.
Diseñamos un proceso de tres pasos:
Formar, equipar y pagar,
para invertir profundamente en que voluntarios como Musu
se conviertan en paraprofesionales,
en personal de salud de la comunidad.
Primero formamos a Musu para prevenir, diagnosticar y tratar
las 10 enfermedades más comunes que afectan a familias de su aldea.
Un enfermero supervisor la visitaba cada mes para formarla.
La equipamos con tecnología médica moderna
como este test rápido para la malaria de 1 dólar.
Lo pusimos en una mochila como esta, llena de medicamentos
para tratar infecciones como la neumonía,
y algo crucial,
un teléfono inteligente, para ayudarla a estar al tanto e informar de epidemias.
Por último, reconocimos la dignidad del trabajo de Musu.
Creamos un contrato con el gobierno de Liberia,
le pagamos,
le dimos la oportunidad de tener un trabajo real.
Y es increíble.
Musu ha aprendido más de 30 habilidades médicas.
Desde examinar a niños en búsqueda de malnutrición,
a evaluar la tos de un niño con su teléfono inteligente,
hasta hacer un seguimiento de personas con VIH
y proveer cuidados periódicos a pacientes que perdieron sus extremidades.
Trabajando en nuestro equipo,
como paraprofesionales,
los trabajadores de salud pueden garantizar
que gran parte de lo que haría tu médico de familia
llegue a lugares donde la mayoría de los médicos de familia no pueden ir.
Una de las cosas que más me gusta es atender a pacientes
con trabajadores de la salud.
El año pasado estaba visitando a A.B.,
y al igual que Musu, A.B. había tenido la oportunidad de ir al colegio.
Estaba en la secundaria, en octavo curso,
cuando sus padres murieron.
Se quedó huérfano y tuvo que dejar.
El año pasado contratamos y formamos a A.B. como asistente de salud.
Atendiendo puerta a puerta
conoció a un niño pequeño llamado Prince,
cuya madre había tenido problemas al darle el pecho,
y cuando tenía seis meses, Prince empezó a consumirse.
A.B. había aprendido a usar una cinta con un código de colores
que se pone alrededor del brazo del niño para diagnosticar malnutrición.
A.B. vio que Prince estaba en la zona roja,
por lo que debía ser hospitalizado.
Entonces A.B. llevó a Prince y a su madre al río,
se subieron en la canoa
y remó 4 horas hasta llegar al hospital.
Más tarde, después de dar el alta a Prince
A.B. enseñó a su madre cómo darle un suplemento alimenticio.
Hace unos meses,
A.B. me llevó a conocer a Price, este pequeño gordinflón de aquí.
(Risas)
Está cumpliendo sus metas, se levanta por sí mismo,
y está empezando a decir algunas palabras.
Esta comunidad me inspira mucho.
A menudo les pregunto por qué hacen lo que hacen,
y cuando le pregunté a A.B.,
me dijo: "Doc, desde que dejé la escuela, es la primera vez
que tengo la oportunidad de tomar un bolígrafo.
Mi cerebro está rejuveneciendo".
Las historias de A.B. y Musu me han enseñado algo fundamental
sobre ser humano.
Nuestro deseo de ayudar a los demás
puede ayudarnos a transformar nuestra propias situaciones.
Hace unos años me conmovió cuán poderoso puede ser el deseo
de ayudar a nuestros vecinos.
Hace unos años,
cuando nos enfrentamos a una catástrofe global.
En diciembre de 2013,
ocurrió algo en la selva a lo largo de la frontera de Guinea.
Una criaturita llamada Emile enfermó con vómitos, fiebre y diarrea.
Él vivía en un área donde las carreteras escaseaban
y había gran escasez de asistentes de salud en la comunidad.
Emile murió,
y en pocas semanas murió su hermana,
semanas después murió su madre.
Esta enfermedad se esparcía de una comunidad a otra.
No fue hasta tres meses después
que el mundo lo reconoció como Ébola.
Con cada minuto perdimos meses,
y el virus se esparcía como la pólvora en toda África occidental,
y por último, en otras partes del mundo.
Las empresas cerraron, las aerolíneas empezaron a cancelar rutas.
A estas alturas de la crisis,
nos dijeron que podrían estar infectadas 1,4 millones de personas
cuando nos dijeron que la mayoría de ellos se moriría,
cuando habíamos perdido casi toda esperanza,
recuerdo estar con un grupo de asistentes de salud
en la selva donde acababa de producirse un brote.
Estábamos formándoles para que se pusieran las máscaras,
los guantes y el traje que necesitaban
para mantenerse a salvo del virus
mientras atendían a sus pacientes.
Recuerdo el miedo en sus ojos.
Y recuerdo no pegar ojo de noche, aterrado pensando en si hice lo correcto
dejándoles en las calles.
Cuando el Ébola amenazó con poner a la humanidad de rodillas,
los trabajadores de salud de Liberia no se rindieron ante el miedo.
Hicieron lo que siempre han hecho:
responder a la llamada para atender a sus vecinos.
Trabajadores de toda Liberia estudiaron los síntomas del Ébola,
hicieron equipo con enfermeros y médicos para ir puerta por puerta
a buscar enfermos y tratarlos.
Seguían a miles de personas que habían sido expuestas al virus
y ayudaron a romper la cadena de transmisión.
Una comunidad de 10 000 trabajadores de la salud arriesgó sus vidas
para ayudar a atrapar el virus y detenerlo en el camino.
(Aplausos)
Hoy, el Ébola está bajo control en África occidental,
y hemos aprendido varias cosas.
Que los puntos ciegos en la asistencia sanitaria rural
pueden convertirse en puntos de contagio,
y en esos lugares todos corremos grandes riesgos.
Que el sistema de emergencia más eficiente
es un sistema del día a día,
y ese sistema tiene que llegar a todas las comunidades,
incluyendo comunidades rurales como la de Emile.
Y sobre todo,
hemos aprendido de la valentía de los trabajadores de salud de Liberia,
que no nos definen las situaciones a las que nos enfrentamos,
sin importar lo desesperanzadoras que parezcan.
Nos define cómo respondemos a ellas.
Los últimos 15 años,
he visto el poder de esta idea
de transformar los ciudadanos de a pie en trabajadores de salud...
en héroes del día a día.
Y funciona en todos lados,
desde los bosques de África occidental,
hasta los pueblos pesqueros de Alaska.
Es cierto,
estos trabajadores de la salud no hacen neurocirugías,
pero hacen que sea posible
llevar la asistencia médica al alcance de todos, en todos lados.
¿Y ahora qué?
Sabemos que todavía mueren millones de personas
de enfermedades prevenibles
en comunidades rurales de todo el mundo.
Y sabemos que la gran mayoría de estas muertes ocurren
en estos 75 países señalados en azul.
También sabemos que
si entrenamos un ejército de trabajadores de la salud
para aprender tan solo 30 destrezas para salvar vidas,
podríamos salvar la vida de casi 30 millones de personas para 2030.
Treinta destrezas podrían salvar 30 millones de vidas para el 2030.
No es solo un plan...
estamos demostrando que se puede hacer.
En Liberia,
el gobierno está formando miles de trabajadores como A.B. y Musu
tras el Ébola,
para llevar la asistencia médica a cada niño y familia del país.
Estamos encantados de trabajar con ellos
y estamos uniendo fuerzas con varias organizaciones
que trabajan en otros países
para ayudarles a hacer lo mismo.
Si podemos ayudar a esos países a hacerlo,
podríamos salvar millones de vidas
y, al mismo tiempo,
podríamos crear millones de empleos.
Sin embargo, sencillamente no se puede hacer sin tecnología.
Nos preocupa que la tecnología nos robe nuestros empleos,
pero cuando se habla de trabajadores de la salud,
la tecnología ha sido vital para crear nuevos empleos.
Sin tecnología... sin este teléfono inteligente,
sin este test rápido...
nos hubiera sido imposible contratar a A.B. y a Musu.
Creo que es hora de que la tecnología nos ayude a formar,
nos ayude a formar personas más rápidamente y mejor que nunca antes.
Como médico,
uso la tecnología para estar al día.
Teléfonos inteligentes, aplicaciones, cursos en línea...
Pero cuando A.B. quiere aprender,
tiene que subirse a esa canoa
e ir al centro de formación.
Y cuando Musu viene a clase,
sus profesores están estancados usando rotafolio y marcadores.
¿Por qué no deberían tener el mismo acceso al aprendizaje que yo?
Si realmente queremos que los asistentes de la salud
dominen estas e incluso más habilidades para salvar vidas
tenemos que cambiar este modelo de educación anticuado.
La tecnología puede cambiar las reglas del juego.
Me asombra la revolución digital en la educación
tal y como la han liderado Khan Academy y edX.
Y creo que ya es hora...
es hora de confrontar
la revolución digital educativa
y la revolución de la salud comunitaria.
Esto me lleva a mi deseo del Premio TED.
Deseo...
que nos ayuden a reclutar
el mayor ejército de trabajadores de salud que el mundo ha conocido
creando la Community Health Academy,
una plataforma global para formar, conectar y empoderar.
(Aplausos)
Gracias.
Esta es la idea:
crearemos y seleccionaremos
los mejores recursos digitales para la educación.
Se los daremos a la comunidad de trabajadores de salud del mundo,
incluyendo a A.B. y a Musu.
Tendrán lecciones en vídeo de cómo vacunar niños
y cursos on-line para detectar el próximo brote,
así no usarán rotafolios.
Ayudaremos a estos países a destacar a estos trabajadores,
para que sean visibles, que no sean infravalorados,
sino que tengan una profesión de renombre, empoderada,
igual que los enfermeros y médicos.
Y crearemos una red de empresas y emprendedores
cuyas innovaciones puedan salvar vidas
y les ayudaremos a conectar con trabajadores como Musu,
para que puedan atender mejor a su comunidad.
Y trabajaremos sin descanso para persuadir a los gobiernos
y hacer de estos trabajadores una piedra angular del sistema de salud.
Queremos probar y prototipar esta academia en Liberia
y algunos países colaboradores,
y planeamos hacerlo global,
incluyendo las áreas rurales del norte de América del Norte
Con el poder de esta plataforma,
creemos que los países pueden ser persuadidos
de que realmente es posible una revolución en la asistencia de salud.
Mi sueño es que esta academia contribuya al aprendizaje
de cientos de miles de miembros de la comunidad
que ayuden a llevar la asistencia sanitaria a sus vecinos...
cientos de millones de ellos
que viven en las comunidades más remotas del mundo,
desde las comunidades boscosas de África occidental,
hasta los pueblos pesqueros de la Alaska rural,
desde las colinas de los Apalaches, hasta las montañas de Afganistán.
Si esta visión se alinea con la de Uds.,
visiten communityhealthacademy.org
y súmense a esta revolución.
Queremos saber si Uds. o su organización o alguien que conocen nos puede ayudar
mientras intentamos construir esta academia durante el próximo año.
Cuando miro a la sala,
me doy cuenta de que un camino no se construye solo,
sino que otros les dan forma.
Hay muchos aquí que han sido parte de esta causa.
Estamos honrados de formar parte de esta comunidad,
de una comunidad que está dispuesta a tomar una causa
tan osada como esta,
así que me gustaría, dejarles una reflexión
para terminar.
Pienso mucho más en lo que me enseñó mi padre.
Hace poco, yo también he sido padre.
Tengo dos hijos,
y mi mujer y yo acabamos de saber que está embarazada del tercero.
(Aplausos)
Gracias.
Hace poco estaba cuidando a una mujer en Liberia
quien, como mi esposa, estaba en su tercer embarazo.
Pero, al contrario que mi esposa,
no había tenido cuidados prenatales con sus dos primeros bebés.
Vivía en una comunidad aislada en un bosque de más de 100 años,
sin ninguna asistencia de salud
hasta que...
hasta que el año pasado un enfermero formó a sus vecinos
para que se convirtiesen en trabajadores de salud.
Aquí estaba yo,
consultando a esta paciente que estaba en su segundo trimestre.
Saqué el ultrasonido para controlar la salud del bebé,
y ella nos empezó a contar historias de sus dos primeros hijos,
yo tenía la sonda en su vientre,
y ella se paró en mitad de la frase.
Giró hacia mí y dijo:
"Doc, ¿qué es ese sonido?"
Es la primera vez que había escuchado el latido de su bebé.
Y sus ojos se iluminaron del mismo modo que mis ojos y los de mi mujer
al escuchar el latido de nuestro hijo.
Durante la historia de la humanidad,
las enfermedades han sido universales y el acceso a la asistencia no.
Un hombre sabio me dijo una vez:
ninguna situación es permanente.
Ya es hora.
Es hora de que vayamos tan lejos como haga falta
para cambiar esta situación juntos.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)